l'équipe en vue de neuf étapes
intervenir l'équipe de déminage et ce
même si votre belle-mère timbo je vous
rappelle l'expression a gardé tout au
long de ce voyage de cette journée c'est
un coup matata
monsieur bonjour hu messieurs dames
bonjour
voila ça va mieux déjà on m'a toujours
dit tu arrives à te sens tu les aimes
non mais j'ai pas d'accent c'est les
autres qui ont un accent les françoises
un accent les collègues ont un accent
mais moi je n'ai pas du tout comme
annoncé dès le départ mesdames messieurs
la piscine et le jacuzzi de ce tronçon
fermé au public n'hésitez pas à mettre
des étiquettes je vous informe que la
première est gratuite la deuxième est
offerte tout allait
bien
mais non messieurs pour les passagers
qui avaient prévu de descendre à miami
honolulu hawaï bora bora bobo dioulasso
et ouagadougou je vous informe que ces
arrêts sont desservies que dans mes
rêves sur mes premières annonces jt le
plus télé c'est qu'on pouvait avoir la
voix et et tremblotante c'était
difficile
[Musique]
[Rires]
4 je peux merci à toi bon ça se passe
bien
nickel souriez depuis longtemps
à yahia quand j'ai pas dans les voitures
les gens m'interpellent je me rappelle
qu' il ya même certaines voix certaines
fois où je suis rentré dans les voitures
et toute la voiture s'est mis à
applaudir et le collègue avec lequel je
t'ai il était il m'a dit c'est la
première fois ça fait longtemps qu'il
fait le train c'est la première fois
qu'ils voient un contrôleur on applaudit
aïe aïe aïe vous voulez me recruter
madame suis chaud
j'ai eu des fois aussi vous le temps
s'était levé un peu avec un voyageur et
tous les autres voyageurs se sont mis à
me défendre parce que derrière on sait
que je ne suis pas là pour emmerder les
gens je suis là dont j'espère vont
travailler alors vous n'avez pas
souscrit une option bagages pour votre
anti net
il le faut ça vous fait vélo par carte
ou en espèces éveil a besoin de pognon
on a l'habitude vous et dès qu'on vous
êtes finalement c'est ça devient
cc coutumier c'est pour moi c'est une
habitude et c'est pas nouveau ce qu'on
me dit en général
pas vraiment non du tout du tout alors
là j'avais des injures que j'imaginais
jamin et par contre je reste stoïque je
laisse point bonjour colline
à
d'accord que là ça va merci à thomas
alors le fait aussi de
de les appeler souvent par leur prénom
ghana qui sont surpris
et puis ça passe ça passe clairement
général donc
super content d'eux
c'est comme si on la connaissait et je
vous informe qu'en bord de ce train vie
que vous n'avez pas de restauration ni
des bars nous essayer au maximum de vous
faire faire un voyage de régime allégé
pas mal de tweets aujourd'hui d'un coup
n'est qu'elle croque le conducteur du 76
21 pensent que c'est le conducteur qui
fait les annonces et surtout quel esprit
il ya moyen de gratter la piscine au
cinquième étage j'informe le passager
nous et a rejoint que la discothèque le
bar dancing et le solarium de ce train
tout situé au cinquième étage sont
fermées au public merci donc de ne rien
oublier avoir de ce train y compris
votre voisin s'il fait partie de vos
bagages
les hits avec mais dieu
merci vous ce que vous vous en fait
c'est vous qui sait moins c'est romain à
la basse et franchement vous est trop
sympa tant mieux avec tout plein de tous
tant mieux
donc le plaisir que j'ai c'est celui des
voyageurs qui arrivent et disent merci
[Musique]